Also ich kann schlecht beweisen, dass ich es nicht war. Also das ist genauso wenig, wie kann ich behaupten, dass ich was nicht habe oder so. Das ist immer schwer. Oft oder einige Fälle gibt es ja auch, wo dann auch tatsächlich mal eine Hausdurchsuchung stattgefunden hat. Und das gibt es auch immer mal wieder mal, wobei das glaube ich mittlerweile weniger geworden ist. Also zumindest dann, wenn es jetzt wirklich an Anführungszeichen kleinere Fälle geht, also wo jetzt nicht irgendwie die Filme wirklich zwei Wochen vor Kinostart irgendwie angeboten worden sind. Also bei sogenannten Release Groups oder sowas. Also wenn ich jetzt normalen Tauschbörsen nutze, da ist es, soweit ich weiß, eigentlich ziemlich wenig, dass da wirklich Hausdurchsuchungen stattfinden. Da ist tatsächlich mehr die Abmahn-Geschichte, die dann problematisch ist. Aber es kann natürlich sein, dass wirklich eine Hausdurchsuchung stattfindet und dann werden die Festplatten, den ganzen Computer, alles mitgenommen. Und dann sind natürlich die Dateien in der Regel darauf, wenn man das nicht verschlüsselt hat, wenn man seine Festplatten nicht verschlüsselt hat.
Aber die sind ja auch drauf, wenn man die Festplatte verschlüsselt hat.
Ja, aber dann sieht sie keiner mehr, wenn man es richtig gemacht hat. Also dann kann man sagen, wenn Schulden anzucken, Passwort vergessen, keine Ahnung, geht es den feuchten Keks an. Ja, Anwalt wird natürlich dann die Fragen und in der Regel wird der Anwalt dann ja, entweder die ganze Sache an Frage stellen, das heißt, ob wir doch erstmal Beweise anfordern, schauen, was liegt eigentlich vor, was hat der Provider geantwortet, könnte möglicherweise bei dem Internet Provider ein Fehler unterlaufen sein, als sie die Kundendaten zu der IP-Adresse rausgesucht haben, welche Beweise, welche Belege hat diese Firma, die die Abmahnung geschickt hat, also zum Beispiel Promedia oder auch Firma Logistep, mal noch mal einen anderen Namen reinzubringen. Was haben die eigentlich genau gemacht, um zu schauen, dass ich derjenige bin, der die Sachen anbietet und was ich da eigentlich anbiete, das heißt, haben die sich das komplett runtergeladen, haben die sich das angeschaut oder haben die nur geguckt, ob der sogenannte Hash-Wert, das ist also eine Quersumme über eine Datei, über die man eigentlich eine Datei eindeutig identifizieren kann, was in der Praxis aber auch problematisch sein kann, weil das auch mal unter bestimmten Umständen zwei unterschiedliche Dateien diesen gleichen Hash-Wert haben können. Das könnte also auch eine Möglichkeit sein. Wie gesagt, wie es ist mit der Uhrzeit, ist alles ordentlich protokolliert. Und ein guter Anwalt findet möglicherweise da schon einen Verfahrensfehler und kann da entsprechend eingreifen und sagen, also hier habt ihr gepennt und eure Kohle kriegt ihr jetzt nicht. In der Regel muss ihr aber den Anwalt trotzdem bezahlen, aber das ist dann meist deutlich weniger als diese Abmahnfirma von mir haben will.
Also nachdem, das ist ja auch ein großes Thema, der Chaosradius oder der Sendung hier auf Fritz gewesen im letzten Jahr, die Vorratsdatenspeicherung, nachdem vor 14 Tagen das Gesetz zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung quasi gekippt wurde und drin stand, dass die Daten, die bei den Providern auflaufen, nicht an jeden sofort rausgegeben werden können, dauerte es keine zwei Stunden. Es war die Pressemeldung der Musikindustrie da, die sagten, das ist natürlich kein Freibrief, dass man jetzt wie ein wahnsinniger Musik aus dem Netz tauschen kann und Musik...
Das würde ich an deren Stelle auch erst mal behaupten...
.Musik durchs Netz schieben kann, sondern es wird natürlich trotzdem weiter verfolgt. Markus hat ja ganz schön kurz mal erklärt, wie das im Falle von ProMedia durchaus dann funktioniert. Gibt es aktuell irgendwelche Fälle, die euch bekannt sind, wo...
Also das große Problem im deutschen Recht ist auch oder im deutschen Justizsystem ist, dass selbst wenn sich hinterher nachträglich rausstellt, dass die Speicherung unzulässig war oder die Herausgabe unzulässig war, heißt es noch lange nicht, also der IP-Adress oder der Kundendaten zu der IP-Adresse heißt es noch lange nicht, dass dann das Verfahren automatisch eingestellt wird oder so. Sondern es ist ja sozusagen dann erst mal möglicherweise, habe ich dann schon irgendwas unterschrieben oder so. Das zieht sich auch alles dann recht lange hin. Und die Fristen bei diesen Abmahnungen sind auch mit Absicht sehr, sehr kurz gesetzt, dass man also gar nicht erst auf die Idee kommt, großartig irgendwelche Sachen in die Wege zu leiten oder da, sag ich mal, großartig zu erkundigen. Die sind mit Absicht schon sehr kurz. Ein Anwalt wird dann auch erst mal eine Fristverlängerung versuchen zu erreichen und dann ein bisschen genau prüfen, Beweise anfordern und sowas, das ist so der übliche Weg.
Also es soll aber auch schon genügend Fälle geben von Menschen, die halt dann einfach entweder ein Fuck You zurückgeschrieben haben oder sich gar nicht mehr gemeldet haben und die dann überhaupt nichts mehr gehört haben.
Filesharing Blue Moon 0331 7097 110 Ich haue nochmal ganz kurze Telefonnummer dazwischen. Denn nicht nur wir drei wollen hier reden, sondern wir wollen vor allen Dingen auch mit euch reden über eure Erfahrung zum Thema Filesharing im Jahre 2008. Und wollen wir schnell Martin nehmen und du deinen Satz noch zu Ende?
Ich wollte eigentlich auch nur fragen, so macht ihr es, macht ihr es nicht? Habt ihr Angst, seid ihr eingeschüchtert worden?
Macht ihr das jetzt anders?
Hast du Angst Martin, machst du das anders?
Nee, also ich nutze jetzt nicht Idonky oder sowas. Sondern ich nutze halt BitTorrent und saug da jetzt auch nicht wild drauf los, sondern gezielt, wenn ich halt was brauche, was ich mal wegen einer Bibliothek nicht finde oder... Also es gibt halt so verschiedene PDF-Dateien oder verschiedene Videos, weiß ich was, wie lern ich Gitarre, die hat man halt auch in der Bibliothek, die sind dann halt selten verfügbar, weil sich halt viele ausbauen und dann schmeißt man einfach mal einen Rechner an und taugt sich da drunter und klar, dass man damit auch Urheberrechte verletzt, aber irgendwie muss man ja auch mal da rankommen, finde ich. Und ja, also jetzt E-Donkey, also E-Nu hat ich früher mal eine Zeit lang genutzt, das wurde mir halt auch zu unsicher.
Kannst du sagen, wann das war etwa? Also was dir das Unsicherheitsgefühl gegeben hat?
Vor zwei Jahren ungefähr. Da habe ich aber eigentlich nur genutzt, um mir halt so ein paar PDF-Dateien runterzuladen. Das waren jetzt ja auch, würde ich sagen, urheberrechtlich geschützte Sachen. Und ein paar Sachen habe ich mir danach im Dach mehr noch gekauft, aber ich finde es teilweise auch einfach praktisch, wenn man sich mal Musik runterlädt, dann hat man es gleich im richtigen Format. Es ist halt ein vernünftiges MP3-Format, alles schon beschriftet. Ich kaufe mir, wenn ich mir sowas runterlade, dann halt auch noch die CD dazu. Quasi stelle ich mir gleichzeitig mit dazu, wenn mir die Musik halt gefällt. Und hab dann halt die CD und das Cover hier rumzuliegen, hab ich ja beim CD-Player, aber halt auf dem Rechner, ist dann schon alles im richtigen Format und ich hab damit nichts mehr zu tun.
Also bist du eigentlich auch ja ein fauler Geselle.
Ja, eigentlich schon. Ist einfach eine schöne praktische Sache, aber was ich mir jetzt ja nicht vorstellen kann, ist, wie man bei Torrents oder Emu oder was auch immer, wie man da unterscheiden soll oder wie man sich sicher sein kann, dass das keine Urheberrechtsverletzung ist, die ich da eingehe. Also es kann ja auch sein, dass da mal was bei ist, was völlig okay ist, was man da runterlädt.
Ja, das ist ein Argument, der das von den Verbraucherschutzverbänden in die ganze Debatte immer reingeschmissen wird. Nämlich ja, wie kann der Verbraucher sicher sein, ob jetzt irgendwie Madonna dahinter steckt oder ob etwas halt freie Musik ist oder nicht. Kann ja einfach irgendwie anders benannt sein und das ist halt ein großes Problem.
Mit welchem Gegenargument kommt denn die andere Seite, die sagt dann, wenn es da drin steht, kannst du davon ausgehen, dass es urheberrechtlich geschätzt ist.
Creative Industries, so ist ja gerade das Zauberwort, um alles zu legitimieren.
Ja, es gibt auch, da muss mich jetzt aber, Markus glaube ich mal korrigieren oder bestätigen, immer noch diese Zusatz, also wenn ein Werk aus offensichtlich rechtswidriger Quelle kommt, ist das eigentlich noch aktuell die Formulierung, gibt es die noch, oder ist die jetzt kürzlich rausgeflogen?
Ich glaube, die haben sie irgendwie umgewandelt, kann ich gleich mal sagen.
Ist denn so ein BitTorrent-Netzwerk, wie sie alle heißen, ich möchte jetzt gar keinen Namen nennen, ist das eine offensichtlich, wie du es gerade nanntest, eine offensichtlich dramatische Quelle?
Tja, gute Frage. Also gerade deswegen war es auch bei All of MC3 zum Beispiel, was wir vorhin hatten, diese russische Seite, die also sehr professionell aufgemacht ist, ist eine Sache, wo ich jetzt sagen würde, das ist jetzt erstmal nicht offensichtlich rechtswidrig. Und das ist auch mal das Argument gewesen. Ich weiß aber auch nicht, da muss jetzt Markus mal schnell schauen, ob diese Formulierung so noch Bestand hat. Aber das ist natürlich so bei einer Tauschbörse, also irgendwie Idanki. Also ein klassisches Beispiel ist immer, wenn jetzt ein Film irgendwie eine Woche vor Kinostart im Netz angeboten wird, dann kann man davon ausgehen, dass es offensichtlich rechtswidrig ist. Aber das ist ja natürlich ein ziemlich großer Graubereich auch auf jeden Fall.
Angenommen, ich lad mir jetzt diesen Film runter. Wenn ich ihn zu Hause entpacke, stellt sich aber heraus, das ist ein Pauno von 1980. Ja gut, aber ich werde jetzt von einem Anwalt angeschrieben, dass ich mir diesen Film heruntergeladen habe. Also nicht den Porno-Film, sondern den Film, weiß ich, was das auch mal sein soll.
Du kannst davon ausgehen, dass das da nicht passieren wird, weil auch die Filmfirma oder die Promedia-Firma oder die Folgungsfirma, sag ich mal, wird diesen Film heruntergeladen haben und auch festgestellt haben, dass das ein Porno ist.
Achso, und dann ist gleich die nächste Frage. Es gibt ja bei E-Mail oder bei den ganzen Tower-Programm gibt es ja immer noch parallel so IP-Filter, die man sich mit herunterladen kann. Und sprich, die ganzen Anwärtskanzleien, die werden ja auch nur IP-Adressen nutzen. Bringt das denn irgendwas, wenn die IP-Adressen bekannt sind, die diese Anwärtskanzleien nutzen und dass die gebannt werden?
Ja, also sagen wir mal so, wenn du halt IP-Filter und so weiter verwendest, dann kann halt ein anderer irgendwie die Arschkarte für dich gezogen haben. Also das ist eigentlich so ein...
Das ist wieder das Schwarzfahrer-Prinzip. Mich würde es schon nicht erwischen, aber vielleicht einen Typen neben mir.
Genau, also vielleicht kann man auch mal irgendwie noch auf die Unterschiedlichkeiten von den Tauschbörsen irgendwie aufmerksam machen. Wir haben auf der einen Seite Betorrent. Betorrent bei, ja, sagen wir mal, man möchte einen Film herunterladen. Macht man das über Betorrent, ist der Film in der Regel, wenn er häufig verfügbar ist, wie ich gehört habe, so in ein bis zwei Stunden unten. Wenn man den Film jetzt über eMool herunterlädt, dann braucht er ja teilweise bis zu zwei, drei Tage. Das bedeutet halt, über eMool bietet man halt der Anwaltskanzlei irgendwie zwei bis drei Tage irgendwie so eine Breitseite an, während man bei Betorrent ja nur zwei Stunden das Risiko eingeht. Wenn man halt weiß, okay, wie viele Arbeitsdrohnen arbeiten bei denen und beobachten Filesharer und wie viele Leute machen überhaupt Filesharing, das sind verdammt viele, kann man sich das Risiko ausrechnen.
Ja gut, klar, aber das ist jetzt nicht so, dass quasi wenn ich diesen IP-Filter an hab, dass sie dann trotzdem meine IP-Adresse rausher. Also ich meine jetzt nur, also angenommen diese Anwaltskanzlei hat jetzt IP-Adressen, die müssen sie ja auch irgendwie haben. Und die werden halt, die fallen halt irgendwie auf.
Ja, aber im Zweifelsfall holen die sich einfach irgendwo bei A-Core, Versatel, Telekom, wo auch immer einfach ein paar DSL-Anschlüsse und dann... Ja, so ganz blöd sind die ja auch nicht. Also die haben halt dynamische IP-Adressen einfach. Und wie gesagt, die lassen sich da einfach 10 DSL-Anschlüsse legen, kriegen jetzt mal eine neue IP-Adresse und da kannst du nix vätern.
Also das ist wahrscheinlich eher Augenwischerei.
Also es gibt in den USA, ist es tatsächlich so, da ist es offensichtlich nicht so üblich mit den dynamischen IP-Adressen oder so, oder aus irgendwelchen nicht nachvollziehbaren Gründen haben die da teilweise feste Adressen. Da sind die IP-Adressbereiche auch bekannt und es gibt auch Peer Guard oder so was. Es gibt ein paar Programme, die man sich installieren kann, die diese IP-Adressbereiche dann abblocken sollen. Aber ich würde mich da jetzt nicht drauf verlassen. Also das ist eher, bringt nichts. Also die Firmen, die tatsächlich einen festen IP-Adressbereich haben, ich glaube, die kann man auch nicht ernst nehmen.
Also Martin, wir bleiben wieder dabei. Du bist eigentlich eine faule Suppe, weil du dir die Dinger aus dem Netz ziehst und du denkst, dass du einfach mit so einem kleinen Programm dich da frei machen kannst. Dem ist nicht so. Es bleibt trotzdem eine offensichtlich rechtswidrige Quelle. Und früher oder später wollen wir hoffen, dass du dir nicht die Finger dabei verbrennst, aber du bist nicht dran.
Also so auf die Propaganda irgendwie eingehen wollen wir halt nicht.
Na, wir wollen aber jetzt auch nicht irgendwie sagen, hurra, alles prima, super.
Und da hat man ja gar keine Wahrheit quasi. Wenn man mit manchem Programm auf dem anderen Sitzen möchte oder mal schnell an irgendwas rankommn möchte, was man sich je bestellt hat oder keine Ahnung, also ich find's...
Also man kann zum Beispiel mal fragen, wo bleiben überhaupt die legalen Angebote, um irgendwie sich Filme im Netz anzuschauen? Ich seh die noch nicht wirklich. Wo sind die legalen Angebote, um zum Beispiel jede Form von Musik, die ich gern haben möchte, in einem nicht Kopierschutzformat in Deutschland herunterzuladen in den USA? Sind da jetzt mp3 Download Stores irgendwie angekündigt? Aber in Deutschland hör ich da immer noch nix. Da werden immer noch irgendwie sehr viel Musik. Zum Glück nicht von den Indie Labels in der Regel, aber zum Beispiel so diese kommerzielle Major Musik wird in der Regel mit Digital Rights Management ausgeliefert und die kann ich bei mir gar nicht abspielen.
und Landesbibliothek, die haben ja schon relativ viele Sachen mit bei und halten sich dann und waren mal so auf dem halbwegs neuen Stand an Werken, die man sich da ausleihen kann. Dann sind die nicht immer verfügbar und dann greift man halt auch mal so aufs Netz zurück. Warum sind solche Anstalten nicht auch mal online?
Ja, aber auch dann haben die halt in der Regel nur ein Werk gekauft, was dann irgendwie dein Nachbar sich gerade ausgeliehen hat und dann darfst du halt auch nicht einfach irgendwie dir eins ausleihen.
Also es gibt auf jeden Fall genug Gründe, warum man auch Musik in Tauschbörsen tauscht. Ganz klar, wenn es irgendwelche Musik gibt, wo es die Platten einfach nicht mehr zu kaufen gibt, dann steht ja auch niemanden Schaden bei. Also behaupte ich jetzt mal so, aber es gibt durchaus genug Fälle, wo man einfach aus meiner Sicht gut im Gewissen diese Tauschbörsen benutzen kann.
Jo, danke auch. Und damit kommen wir gleich zum nächsten, nämlich zu Sam, mit einer sehr berechtigten Frage. Hallo Sam, guten Abend.
Ja, guten Abend.
Schieß los.
Und zwar, ich oute mich mal erstmal als Falschherrer. Ich tue das gerne und ich tue es oft. Und für mich sieht das irgendwie total absurd aus, dass irgendeine Firma hingehen kann, sich zu einem Bitterrent-Tracker verbinden kann, der Epis davon nehmt und einfach sagt, der war's. Oder sich zu mir verbindet, während ich irgendwas schere und danach irgendwann mal in einem Gerichtsprozess sagt, der war's.
Interessante Frage ist, dürfen die das überhaupt? Wer ein bisschen die Geschichte mitverfolgt hat oder das Thema mitverfolgt hat, gerade in der letzten Zeit gab es zwei Sachen, einmal in der Schweiz und in Italien auch, wo also jeweils die Datenschutzbeauftragten der Länder mal in Frage gestellt haben, ob diese Firmen überhaupt berechtigt sind, sagen wir mal, personenbezogene Daten an der Stelle über die Benutzer zu erheben und zu speichern und zu verarbeiten. Die haben ja da gar nicht eingewilligt, dass deren Tauschverhalten irgendwie gespeichert wird. Und die haben also sozusagen die Legitimation oder die rechtliche Konstruktion dieser Firmen, der Abmahnfirmen, in Frage gestellt. Ich weiß nicht, ob es in Deutschland auch so weit kommen wird. Es ist auf jeden Fall eine ziemlich gewagte Rangehensweise. Aber zumindest in der Schweiz und Italien haben die sich jetzt erst mal lautstark dazu geäußert und sind den Firmen, die das machen, auch deutlich auf den Fuß getreten damit.
Aber das beantwortet nicht wirklich die Frage. Also es ist ja schön, dass die Leute sagen, also das, was ihr macht, geht nicht. Aber ich meine ja nicht darum, mir geht es ja nicht darum, dass es illegal ist, was die machen, sondern für mich ist diese Konstruktion, ja, du hast jetzt irgendwie ein paar Beizümer die Leitung geschickt und das ist jetzt illegal. Beziehungsweise wir sagen dem Gericht, dass du irgendwelche Beizümer geschickt hast, die angeblichen Teilen des MP3s warst.
Also das ist die moralische Frage, ob jetzt hier quasi Selbstjustiz in Ordnung ist oder nicht?
Nein, für mich ist einfach nur die Frage, warum glaubt das jemand überhaupt denen? Die können das alles selber noch konstruieren.
Moment, Moment, also wenn ich richtig verstanden habe, es geht gar nicht um eine Konstruierung, sondern sie sind Teil dieses Netzwerks, in dem du auch bist. Sie sehen deine IP-Adresse und können dann sagen, Sam aus Notendurzeldorf, Stadtteil so und so, mit der und der IP-Adresse war zu dem Zeitpunkt da.
Das ist auch die gleiche Geschichte wie beim Kaufhaus beim Ladendetektiv. Der Ladendetektiv erwischt dich beim Klauen und sagt, hier, ich hab gesehen, du hast das eingesteckt. Problematisch ist natürlich dann, wenn er die Sache dann nicht findet. Dann steht er natürlich ziemlich blöd da. Die Frage ist, ob du wirklich dann riskierst, dass du sagst, okay, wir brauchen halt sofort das SEK, was bei den Leuten zu Hause reinstürmt und die Wohnung durchsucht und irgendwie die Festplatten beschlagnimmt, wenn man es jetzt wirklich so konkret machen will, was ja dann der Schritt wäre.
Zukünftig einfach das Internet.
Ja, aber genau wie du sagst, der Laden, der hat ja irgendwie diese Süßigkeit, die ich mir in die Tasche gesteckt hab, hat er mir dann aus der Tasche gezogen.
Oder ein Zeuge der irgendwas, ganz normaler Zeuge, der irgendwas beobachtet. Kann ja auch eine Privatperson sein, muss ja jetzt kein Polizist sein. Zeuge kann ja irgendjemand sein und der sagt dann vor Gericht irgendwas aus und das Gleiche ist natürlich auch da. Ob dir das Gericht in dein entsprechend Glauben schenkt, das ist ja tatsächlich eine Frage immer. Und deswegen lohnt sich an vielen Fällen bestimmt auch, es tatsächlich auf den Prozess ankommen zu lassen, wenn er denn überhaupt niemals stattfinden wird, wenn also diese Firma überhaupt es wagt, einen ordentlichen Prozess anzutreten. Weil natürlich immer eine gewisse Wahrscheinlichkeit besteht. Es hängt davon ab, wie fit dein Anwalt ist, den du gesucht hast. Ob er da irgendwelche Prozessfehler findet, irgendwelche formalen Fehler. Und dann sagt, ja, wie zum Beispiel in einem Fall, wo also der Geschäftsführer gesagt hat, ja, ich genau gesehen, ich war genau dabei. Und dann hat der Richter mal nachgefragt, wirklich, oder war es einer ihrer Angestellten? Ja, es war einer meiner Angestellten. Das heißt, sie haben uns nicht die Wahrheit erzählt. Schönen Dank, Sie können jetzt gehen, die Sache ist beendet. So schnell kann es denn gehen, aber das sind alles Sachen, da würde ich mich jetzt auch nicht darauf verlassen, dass es beim nächsten Mal auch wieder geht. Die Firmen lernen an der Stelle auch dazu.
Ja, aber was ich für ein Problem sehe, normalerweise ist ein Zeuge ja ein neutraler Dritter in diesem Fall, aber verschmilzt der Zeuge mit dem Ankläger. Das ist ein und dieselbe Person.
Ja, aber das ist halt so. Also wenn du irgendwie bei deinem Nachbarn hingehst und die Tür eintrittst und er war dabei und zeigt dich an, dann ist er vor Gericht auch gleichzeitig Zeuge und Ankläger.
Ja, aber der kann das mir niemals nachweisen, wenn da wirklich keine dritten Leute dabei waren oder sonst irgendwie das nachgewiesen werden kann.
Also im Zweifelsfall gucken da zwei Leute drauf. Und die werden dann vereidigt. Und dann hast du natürlich als einer, der sagt, ich war das aber gar nicht, im Zweifelsfall den schlechteren Karten. Aber wie gesagt, das ist eine Sache, wie das vor Gericht ausgeht. Und wenn der Anwalt sagt, ja, das lassen wir mal drauf ankommen, dann...
Aber die beiden Leute, die da sind, die arbeiten, die werden ja dafür bezahlt, dass die Leute will mich erwischen. Also die könnten einfach mal dumm gesagt lügen. Einfach mal sagen, ja, die IP 127 001, die war's.
Aber im Zweifelsfall wären die vereidigt. Und dann können sie nicht lügen. Wenn sie halt doch lügen, dann machen sie sich einfach strafbar. Und zwar richtig doll.
Und in dem Fall ist es glaube ich, hängt es immer sehr von den Details ab, die da alle mit drum rum zu finden sind.
Und was ist, Moment, ich habe eine zweite Frage. Und was ist, wenn ich das darauf wirklich weiter ankommen lasse und sage, ja, weißt du mir bitte nach, dass ich die Datei habe? Und kommen die hier an mit der Hausdurchsuchung, nehmen meine Server mit, meine komplette Serverfarm auf 23 Servern? Und ja, was machen die dann, wenn die sagen, ich bin der üble Terrorist, der die Daten verschlüsselt?
Ja, nee, das geht dann nur für Gerichte. Du kannst halt sagen, du klagst halt dagegen und dann brauchst du halt finanzielle Ressourcen, um quasi so ein paar Instanzen durchzustehen.
Ja, das kommt wirklich nur darauf an, die lassen einfach nur darauf ankommen, dass der Normalbürger sich gar nicht traut, so einen kostspieligen Gerichtsverfahren mitzumachen.
Kurz zusammengefasst, ja.
Und um hinten dran zu schieben, wir können im Einzelfall keine konkrete Rechtsberatung geben. Wenn du da Detailfragen hast, dich dann einfach mal mit dem Anwalt deines Vertrauens unterhalten.
Ich kann mal kurz etwas weggeben, wir kommen ja leider nicht auf IRC, aber in meinen Kommentaren hat ein Don A287 geschrieben, dass die IP-Filter im Bereich eMool, über die wir eben gesprochen haben, nicht dazu dienen, den User abzusichern, sondern die sollen nur bekannt gewordene mutmaßliche Verbreiter von fehlerhaften Paketen und Shanks aussperren. Also das ist halt eher so, um überflüssige Informationen wegzumachen. Und Tim meinte gerade über Twitter, dass vier Fragen zur Verfolgbarkeit von BitTorrent, das Chaosradio Express Nummer 57, sehr gut leistet.
Richtig, guter Hinweis, genau, Chaosradio Express können wir auch nochmal wieder drauf verweisen. Da gibt es ganz, ganz viele Hintergrundinformationen, das sind vielleicht Sachen, die viele von euch ein bisschen vermissen in der letzten Zeit, nämlich die technischen Detailfragen, die dann teilweise auch sehr nerdig sind. Aber alles, was ihr sozusagen noch mehr darüber hinaus wissen wollt, also alles, was euch, sag ich mal, an technischen Details hier zu kurz kommt, gibt es auf jeden Fall auch im Chaosradio Express nachzuhören. Das ist ein Podcast, der unregelmäßig regelmäßig rauskommt. Und da gibt es auch was zum Thema BitTorrent.
Alles unter chaosradio.de.
Genau, wo man also auch diese Sendung, die hier stattfindet, sich als Podcast in Ruhe noch mal mitnehmen kann und sich in Ruhe zu Gemüte führen kann. Guten Abend nach Thorsten, zu Thorsten. Hallo Thorsten. Wir kommen jetzt mal wieder zu Musik, nachdem wir uns jetzt sehr viel in technischen Details von Serverfarben beschäftigt haben.
Ich meine, die Debatte, die bisher geführt wurde, ist natürlich auch ein bisschen müßig auf Dauer. Das ist, glaube ich, auch eine Debatte der Musikindustrie oder generell der Content-Industrie über die Verteidigung ihrer eigenen Geschäftsmodelle. Und ich glaube, das gehört letztendlich der Vergangenheit an. Man muss ja auch mal fragen, wie kann man eigentlich Geld verdienen als Künstler im Internet?
Du kommst jetzt garantiert mit zwei aktuellen Beispielen.
Das eine aktuelle Beispiel ist halt die Ben 9 Schnells, die vor kurzem ihr neustes Werk im Internet-Distribut verteilt hat. Man konnte sich verschiedene Bezahlmodelle sozusagen aussuchen. Das fing an bei 5 Dollar, den Download, für den Download. Und es ging hoch bis zu einem exklusiven Vinyl- und CD-Album für 300 Dollar mit persönlicher Signatur von Trent Reznor.
Das ist im Endeffekt dieselbe Geschichte, die Radiohead auch gemacht hat.
Genau. Und ich weiß jetzt die konkreten Zahlen nicht ganz genau, aber ich meine innerhalb der ersten Woche waren sie schon über eine Million Dollar, die sie damit verdient haben, was natürlich auch nicht schlecht ist. Also das ist, glaube ich, eine ganz gute Ausbeute. Und ich glaube, da liegt einfach die Zukunft. Und die Musikindustrie hat es einfach nicht verstanden, das Internet als Verteil, als Verteilmedium zu nutzen. Und das wird sie, glaube ich, auch nicht verstehen. Denn das Problem bei diesem aktuellen, nein, ein schnelles Beispiel ist einfach, dass die Musikindustrie da schlicht und ergreifend nicht vorkommt. Denn die Band hat es selber in die Hand genommen, ihr Album zu verteilen.
Genau, das ist ein Deal zwischen Trent Reisner und seinem Fan.
Genau. Und im Übrigen war es dann auch so, ich glaube, man musste es irgendwie kaufen, um da erst mal ranzukommen. Man konnte aber und kann es nach wie vor weiter verteilen. Also ich kann jetzt sozusagen das Album, was ich gekauft habe, bei BitTorrent oder sonst wo reinstellen, weil eben Nine Inch Nails auf ihr klassisches Recht das selber zu verteilen verzichten haben und gesagt haben, okay, die User, die kaufen es und können es dann auch weitergeben. Und zwar nicht nur an die berühmten fünf oder sieben Freunde nach deutscher Rechtsprechung, sozusagen die Privatpuppi, sondern an wen auch immer.
An der Stelle zwei Einwände ganz kurz. Zum einen gab es gerade eine Diskussion mit auch Bands aus Deutschland zu dieser Geschichte, die wir bei Fritz auch geführt haben, unter anderem mit den Beat Stakes, die sagten, wenn man Radiohead ist oder Nine Inch Nails und mehrere Millionen Platten schon verkauft hat, dann kann man sich so ein Geschäftsmodell auf jeden Fall erlauben. Aber wenn man eine kleinere Band ist, die nicht sozusagen das finanzielle Polster hat, auszuprobieren, was passiert und im Zweifelsfall nichts damit zu verdienen, dann ist dieses Modell natürlich ein bisschen schwierig. Aber die Idee dahinter an sich ist auf jeden Fall cool. Markus?
Genau Radiohead und Nine Inch Nails haben in diesem Fall eigentlich auch nur Geschäftsmodelle aus dem Internet kopiert. Sie hatten natürlich den Vorteil, sie haben schon eine riesige Community drum herum. Aber eigentlich ist das durch Netlabels, die so vorgehensweise dieses Geschäftsmodell groß geworden und bekannt geworden. Und es gibt beispielsweise magnatune.com. Das ist ein britisches Netlabel, die genauso wie Nine Inch Nails Musik unter einer Creative Commons Lizenz veröffentlicht haben. Das heißt, bestimmte Nutzungsfreiheiten werden von den Urhebern gewährt. In diesem Fall halt die Weitergabe zu nicht kommerziellen Zwecken. Also man darf es weiter kopieren, man darf es auch unter bestimmten Bedingungen remixen. Und MagnaTune verdient einerseits dadurch, dass sie halt über 50 Künstler haben und eine ganze Menge Musik. Und man kann halt diese Musik auf CD erwerben, wenn man möchte. Man kann sie aber auch zu einem selbst definierten Preis downloaden. Diese CD wiederum bietet auch nur einen Mehrwert an. Also einen Mehrwert quasi, indem man halt sagt, ich möchte was haptisches haben. Dafür zahle ich halt gern 10 Euro und schickt sie mir. Gleichzeitig verdient MagnaTune am meisten Geld im sogenannten B2B Bereich. Also sie nehmen halt dem Wissen des zu Konsumer Bereich. Also ich verkaufe mehr Werte oder ihr zahlt mir das was ihr für notwendig haltet. Lizenzieren sie sehr viel für Werbung, für Dokumentarfilme und so weiter. Und kriegen da halt tatsächlich am meisten Geld. Und kriegen ansonsten sehr viel Aufmerksamkeit über dieses andere Modell.
Tausend geschlagte vor, dass wir, wir müssen ja gleich die Nachricht machen, dass wir bis zu den Nachrichten noch ein Stückchen aus diesem Radiohead Album hören. Und jeder der sich mit dem Gedanken schwanger trägt, Musik zu machen und davon leben zu wollen, kann sich ja schon mal überlegen, wie er die erste Million Platten absetzt, damit er bei der zweiten Platte sich so ein Geschäftsmodell auch erlauben kann.
Ja okay, vielleicht noch ein ganz kurzer Hinweis zum Thema Net Labels. Gibt es auch ein Chaosradio Express. Da kann man jetzt auch noch mal alles nachhören, welche Geschäftsmodelle dahinter stecken, wie sich es in der Praxis so bewährt. Auch sehr empfehlenswert.
Hallo, ich bin Christian Ullmann und neben mir steht die liebe Kathrin Thüring, Tagchen. Genau, zusammen haben wir vor kurzem eine Sendung moderiert, die hieß, die hieß, woher sollen wir das wissen? Ah ja, genau, jetzt geht das endlich weiter. Quasi, woher sollen wir das wissen? Oder woher sollen wir das wissen? Reloaded? Die Rückkehr der Besserwisser? Oder woher sollen wir das wissen? Jetzt erst Recht? Blah, Blah, jedenfalls brauchen wir dafür eure Hilfe.
Denn dieses Mal stellt ihr die Fragen und helft uns bei der Auflösung.
Und das alles im Blue Moon.
Fritz präsentiert, woher sollen wir das wissen? Der Blue Moon mit Christian Ullmann und Kathrin Thüring.
Habt ihr unfassbar spannende, oft gestellte, doch nie geklärte, vor allem ganz schön verzwickte Fragen?
Dann schickt sie per Mail mit Name und Telefonnummer an wissen-at-fritz.de und seid live dabei, wenn es wieder heißt, woher sollen wir das wissen? Ab Donnerstag, 3.
April.
Und dann achtmal am Donnerstag ab 22 Uhr.
Mehr Infos fritz.de Und?
Wird das lustig?
Fripp Info Nachricht Mit Matthias Zachau Auch die Deutschen kommen nach Einschätzung von Forschern extreme Wetterlagen und enorme Kosten als Folge des Klimawandels zu. Das Deutsche Institut für Wirtschaftsforschung rechnet damit, dass die Landwirtschaft unter immer mehr heißen Sommern leiden und die Ernte zurückgehen werde. Auch die Energieversorgung könnte gefährdet werden, wenn Kraftwerke bei extremer Hitze kein Kühlwasser mehr haben. In den nächsten 50 Jahren könnten Kosten von rund 800 Milliarden Euro wegen des Klimawandels entstehen. Das DIW hat die Studie auf einer Tagung in Hamburg vorgelegt. Rund 700 Teilnehmer beraten dort über extreme Wetterlagen. US-Präsident Bush hat mit Chinas Staatschef Hu Jintao telefoniert und sich besorgt über das Vorgehen Pekinx in Tibet geäußert. Bush appellierte an Hu Gespräche mit dem geistlichen Oberhaupt der Tibetern, dem Dalai Lama aufzunehmen und Diplomaten in die Unruheregion zu lassen. Auch das Europäische Parlament kritisierte das Vorgehen der chinesischen Behörden, allerdings waren sich die Parlamentarier nicht einig über einen möglichen Boykott der Olympischen Spiele in Peking. Vor allem Konservative und Grüne waren dafür, Sozialdemokraten meist dagegen. SPD und Grüne in Hessen wollen die Studiengebühren wieder abschaffen. Beide Parteien legten in Wiesbaden ein gemeinsames Konzept vor. Neben den allgemeinen Studiengebühren von 500 Euro pro Semester sollen auch die Gebühren für Langzeitstudenten wegfallen. Die Einnahmen, die den Hochschulen wegfallen, sollen sie vom Land bekommen. Die Abschaffung der Studiengebühren war Bestandteil der Wahlprogramme von SPD, Grünen und Linkspartei, die zusammen eine Mehrheit im neuen Landtag haben. Die deutsche Fußballnationalmannschaft hat das EM-Testspiel gegen die Schweiz mit 4 zu 0 gewonnen. Die Tore schossen Klose, zweimal Gomez und Podolski. Die Eisbären Berlin sind ins Playoff-Halbfinale der deutschen Liga eingezogen. Die Berliner gewannen gegen die Hamburg Freezers 4 zu 3 in der Verlängerung. Im Halbfinale über maximal fünf Spiele treffen die Eisbären ab dem 1. April auf die DEG Metro Stars aus Düsseldorf. Wetter Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen Potsdam-Frankfurt, Wittenberge und Angermünde minus 1 Grad, Cottbus und Neuropie 0 und auch in Berlin 0 Grad. Die Temperaturen gehen in der Nacht runter bis auf minus 5 Grad. Schnee und Graubeschauer lassen langsam nach. Morgen wird es dann ein recht freundlicher Tag. Es bleibt meist trocken bei Höchstwerten zwischen 6 und 9 Grad. A10 südlicher Berliner Ring Richtung Potsdam. Zwischen Rassplatz Siedener-Elzbruch und Dreierknutetal haben wir Stau. A12 Richtung Berlin, auch zwischen Fürstenwalde West und Storkow staut zurzeit. A13 Richtung Dresden, zwischen Ruland und Ortrand gibt es immer noch Behinderungen wegen eines kaputten LKWs, der rechte Fahrstreifen ist blockiert. Und A24 von Berlin kommend, zwischen Dreierquitsch, Stockdosse und Sukow fährt ein Schwertransport. Hier bitte Vorsicht, ansonsten euch eine gute Fahrt. Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBW.
Und wenn im Radio 103, 2, dann fritz rund um Sprenne.
Blum, die zwei Sprechstunden.
Oh, leere Taschen, die Trinken waschen, die ganzen Getränke und die morschen Gelenke, die geprabbelten Wörter, der gedunstene Körper, meine Ansichten und die lieben Geschichten. Und wenn sie mich sehen, werden sie mich verstehen. Die schleckten Verstecke, die herren Gedecke, die verlorenen Wochenlenden, der Trieb meiner Lenden, die schlechten Gerüche, die tierlichen Sprüche, die falschen Wahlen und die gerechten Fahnen. Und wenn sie mich sehen, werden sie mich verstehen. Kein Lippenstift auf meinem Kragen, feste Spuren auf meinen Schuhen. Schuhen. Nur die verlorenen Freunde, die gestorbene Träume, die Normalitäten, abgebrochene Diäten, selbstverschuldete Ängste und geduldete Zwänge, die leeren Taschen und die tristen Maschen. Der Lippen stirbt auf meinem Kragen. Fisselspuren auf meinem Schuh. Sehen, werden sie mit verstehen. Mein Gott, ich bereue alles.
Hallo Mona Fritz, letzter Mittwoch im Monat, Chaos Radio Teil 133. Das war ein Superpunk mit Ja, ich bereue alles. Im Chaos Radio reden wir heute über Filesharing. Markus Becke da, alles da, von netzpolitik.org. Frank Rosengrad vom Chaos Computer Club ist hier. Mein Name ist Jakob Kranz. Wir würden uns über eure Anrufe freuen unter der 0331 70 97 110. Wir reden über Filesharing, eure Erfahrung beim Filesharing im Jahre 2008, auch nach der Vorwärtsdatenspeicherung. Hat sich euer Verhalten beim Filesharing oder beim Surfen verändert? Habt ihr Angst, wenn ihr euch in diesen Tauschbörsen bewegt? Nutzt ihr den nicht mehr? Macht ihr irgendwelche anderen Sachen? Wir haben uns schon ein bisschen genähert der dynamischen IP-Adresse. Wir haben erfahren, stellenweise wie ProMedia, die ProMedia GmbH funktioniert, die also Filesharer jagt. Und wir haben auch schon erfahren, dass sowohl Up als auch Download, also das Anbieten und das Saugen von urheberrechtlich geschützten Dateien, rechtswidrig ist und dass da nicht das Unwissen schützt zu sagen, ich wusste ja gar nicht, was alles dabei ist. Nächste am Telefon ist Felix. Hallo Felix. Na, Wendt.
Deine Frage.
Ja, also ich hab mir vorhin mal überlegt, also ein Freund von mir, der geht völlig sorglos mit Filesharing um, er hat sein Rechner Tag und Nacht laufen und ist sich da ständig irgendwas am ziehen. Aber da bin ich schon immer darauf am warten, dass der mal irgendwann mal Post bekommt. Bei mir ist es so, dass ich also tatsächlich seit ner ganzen Zeit jetzt darauf verzichte, irgendwie Musik aus dem Internet zu laden. Und also die Sachen, die ich lade irgendwie über BitTorrent, das sind eigentlich mal Sachen, die jetzt so gar nicht lizenziert sind in Deutschland. Also die man auch sonst nur woher bekommt, die vielleicht irgendwo im fernen Asien lizenziert sind und vielleicht irgendwann in 20 Jahren hier auf den deutschen Markt kommen. Und insofern fühl ich mich da eigentlich mal relativ sicher, weil ich denke also, dass da jetzt niemand, weil es da keinen deutschen Markt gibt, da jetzt niemand auf die Idee kommt, das zu verfolgen. Aber meine Frage ist eigentlich eine ganz andere. Und zwar, mich würde mal interessieren, ob jetzt eigentlich überhaupt der Versuch, das herunterzuladen, strafbar ist. Also man hört ja immer so diesen Spruch, der Versuch ist strafbar, das ist die Frage.
Also du meinst jetzt, um das mal zusammenzufassen, wenn du also ein BitTorrent-Netzwerk hast, wo man also von verschiedenen Leuten immer so einzelne Schnipselen bekommt, ob der einzelne Schnipsel schon ausreicht, zu sagen, das ist offensichtlich recht schwierig.
Also gerade bei Torrent ist es ja so, dass ich mir in der Regel erstmal von so einer Webseite oder von einem Freund ein sogenanntes Torrent-File bekomme, was sozusagen wie so ein Index ist oder ein Hinweis irgendwo drauf hin. Und da ist es glaube ich ziemlich unstrittig, dass das Runterladen von diesem Torrent-File erstmal nichts Relevantes ist, weil das ist ja kein urheberrechtlich geschütztes Material.
Das ist ja nur ein Link, ja.
Das ist ein Link sozusagen. Und ob das Anbieten davon jetzt möglicherweise, also dann muss man dann auch wieder deutlich trennen zwischen tatsächlich der Strafbarkeit und der zivilrechtlichen Ansprüchen, Unterlassungsansprüchen. Da ist dann auch oftmals der Gesamtschau interessant. Das heißt, wenn jetzt ein Richter raufschaut, ist es jetzt zivilrechtlich, gibt es einen Unterlassungsanspruch, dann schaut er, wie sieht das Angebot aus? Also ist das jetzt sozusagen mal so eine einmalige Sache? Oder ist das jetzt da eine Webseite, die darauf ausgerichtet ist, Urheberrechtsverletzungen im großen Stil zu ermöglichen?
Aber um auf die Frage von Felix einzugehen, ist also der Schnipsel eines Torrent-Files. Ist das schon ein Problem?
Jetzt könntest du es ja nicht angehen, aber ich weiß es.
Also grundsätzlich ist es so, dass auch 10 Sekunden von einem Musikstück auch urheberrechtlich geschützt sind. Also ist jetzt nicht nur so, dass ein Musikstück erst dann urheberrechtlich geschützt ist, wenn es komplett auf meiner Festplatte ist, sondern auch wenn ich nur die ersten 10 Sekunden habe oder irgendwo in der Mitte 30 Sekunden mal hab, einen Block, dann ist es natürlich auch urheberrechtlich geschütztes Material.
Ja, ich hab mich nicht öfter mal überlegt. Das war die Frage, weswegen ich eigentlich angerufen hatte, weil ich hatte bis jetzt immer nur gehört, dass diese Anwaltskanzleien, die Abmahnkanzleien da irgendwie immer gucken, wer die Sachen anbietet. Und hatte bis jetzt noch nie davon gehört, dass tatsächlich die Leute verfolgt werden, die jetzt irgendwie downloaden. Also da haben wir drüber geredet, genau. Und jetzt hatte ich mich überlegt, wie kann man das überhaupt technisch machen? Weil das sind ja alles Peer-to-Peer-Netzwerke. Wie kann man das jetzt rauskriegen, ob jetzt irgendjemand von irgendjemandem an was downloadet? Da habe ich mich gefreut, wie das technisch gehen kann.
Also da gibt es einen juristischen Fachbegriff des Anscheinbeweises dafür. Das heißt, wenn der Richter hinreichend davon überzeugt ist, dass es so war, dann würde er das auch erst mal so hinnehmen. Das heißt, wenn die glaubhaft machen, wir haben jetzt hier die Tauschbörse und wir haben jetzt irgendwie, sage ich mal, 20 Prozent, also irgendwie zwei von zehn Blöcken oder so was, haben wir jetzt von ihm runtergeladen und zum Schluss kam eben dieses Musikstück raus, dann können wir wohl davon ausgehen, dass der auch das Musikstück da angeboten hat.
Ja, aber wie ist das, wenn ich es downloade? Wie kriegen die das raus? Wenn ich jetzt hier von meinem Rechner aus, jetzt von einem ganz anderen Rechner, von einem Freund sage ich mal, da das Stück unterlade.
Also wenn du eine Tauschbör oder ein System hast, was tatsächlich hundertprozentig nur downloadet und nicht uploadet, also auf keinen Fall irgendwelche Sachen für andere zur Verfügung stellt, dann wird es natürlich schwer, weil in dem Fall, wo sie das dann anbieten, also angenommen, der Rechteinhaber würde das selbst anbieten, dann würde es ja auch zum Download frei geben quasi, also dann würde er auch die Rechte verlieren oder verliert in der Praxis auch die Rechte.
Nee, das sind sogenannte Honeypots.
Das ist richtig, aber da gibt es ja die Geschichten mit der GVU, die möglicherweise auch selbst Server betrieben haben sollte. Und da gibt es zumindest unter Juristen verbreitet die Ansicht, dass in dem Moment, wo also dann der Rechteinhaber selbst an der Verbreitung, an der vermeintlich illegalen Verbreitung beteiligt ist, verliert er auch die Rechte.
Ja, aber ist er eigentlich auch, also wenn ich noch an früher denke, wie Emul da aussah, man lädt sich eine Datei runter und sieht dann, bei welchen Leuten man in der Warteschlange drin steht, quasi. Und man befindet sich da eigentlich auch schon, um an diese Datenwörbler ranzukommen in einem solchen Prozess.
Das ist richtig, aber das ist tatsächlich die Frage, ist es dann schon so?
Und da können wir jetzt aber juristisch nicht...
Juristisch können wir dazu nichts sagen. Da geht es ja darum, den Richter zu überzeugen. Es kann jetzt sein, der Richter sagt, ja, war halt der Versuch, aber der hat ja noch nichts auf der Festplatte gehabt. Machen wir jetzt nichts weiter. Ich kann sagen, ja klar, das ist ja eine Tauschbörse. Also das engt auch mal vom Richter ab.
Also auch hier können wir sagen, es gibt keine allgemein gültige Formel dafür. Im Zweifelsfall, wenn du da Bauchschmerzen hast, Felix, unterhalte dich mit dem Rechtsanwalt deines Vertrauens.
Ja, Fioris ist eigentlich der Streitbettbett, das ist bei so einer Sache mittlerweile, bei einem Song.
Das ist total unterschiedlich. Wir haben da zum Beispiel das Landgericht Köln, die berechnen 10.000 Euro. Also wenn man drei Alben irgendwie bereitstellt, dann hat man Streitwert von einer halben Million Euro Schaden.
Also ganz kurz, der Streitwert ist sozusagen der strittige Wert, um den es geht. Und der ist deswegen sehr besonders interessant, weil sich die Vergütung des Rechtsanwaltes oder der der Abmahnkanzlei auch danach richtet.
Genau, aber Landgericht Köln ist bisher Spitzenreiter in Deutschland. Da scheint die Richterin in so einem Gerichtsurteil aus dem letzten Jahr irgendwie sehr musikoindustriefreundlich gewesen zu sein. Dann gibt es halt Hamburg, die haben gleich einen Streitwertkatalog entwickelt. Da wird das alles gestaffelt, also 6000 Euro für den ersten Song, 3000 Euro für den zweiten bis fünften Song, so 1500 Euro für den sechsten bis zehnten Song. Und ab dann wird es immer billiger. Also insgesamt dieser Streitwertkatalog folgt aus dem Wettbewerbsrecht. Und insgesamt ist das aber sehr problematisch, weil mit so einem hohen Streitwert kommt man auf generalpräventive Erwägungen durch die Gerichte. Und das ist ein großes Problem. Weil so ein juristischer Streit zwischen juristischen Problemen darf ja nicht so die allgemeinen Probleme der Musikindustrie betreffen. Und das ist halt relativ unrealistisch dadurch.
Das heißt jetzt was?
Ja, also irgendwie im Wettbewerbsrecht ist das eigentlich so, dass man das halt juristisch irgendwie trennen müsste.
Um da kurz mal einzugrenzen. Weil ich glaube, du wirst jetzt sehr nerdy, sehr technisch und sehr juristisch. Felix, ich danke dir erstmal für den Anruf. Und wir gehen mal nach Leipzig. Da kommt nämlich Hans her. Der hat angerufen und es geht jetzt. Wir haben viel über Filesharing geredet, die ganzen Probleme. Hans sagt, Filesharing ist von vorgestern. Es gibt Alternativen. Name, Hans.
Das, denke ich, kann man einfach so weiter da beibehalten. Die Plattform, wo man sich die Musik runterholt, ist die interessante, die ich hier mal kurz vorstellen möchte. Ich weiß nicht, ob es schon gesagt wurde. Das jamendo.com, das ist so ein großes französisches Musikportal, die jetzt mittlerweile über 7.900 Alben von Musikern anbieten, die per P2P unterzuladen sind. Alles mit Creative Commons Lizenz und ja, kostenfrei und sicher, dass man dort nicht verfolgt wird. Von übereifrigen Anwälten. Amüsant finde ich übrigens auch die Diskussionskultur, wie sie jetzt so ein bisschen angelegt wurde. Das erinnert mich ein bisschen an die 90er, wo Computerzeitschriften angeschrieben wurden, weil Benutzer ihr Code-Rad für ihr Monkey Island Spiel verloren haben. Es können dann immer solche Ausflüchte, ja ich habe das Spiel ja original gekauft, aber mein Code ist weg. Ich kann es jetzt leider nicht mehr benutzen. Genauso wird hier argumentiert. Ich brauche jetzt das Lied und nur das eine Lied. Und ich weiß, dass ich jetzt hier oben Verstoß begehe, aber die Content-Mafia ist ja so schlimm. Die haben es nicht anders verdient. Ich finde das ist ein bisschen Bigot an der Stelle. Interessant natürlich euer Einwurf. Es handelt sich nur erstmal um Transportprotokoll. Das P2P. Aber wenn es dann eben gesagt wird, es braucht wird, um sich diesen geschützten Content runterzuziehen, dann wird das Ganze natürlich ad absurdum geführt. Und wenn sie jetzt mittlerweile schon über eine Stunde darum die Sendung dreht, wie man am besten argumentieren kann, bei einem Anwalt oder vor dem Gericht, wie man irgendeinen Schaden abwenden kann, wenn es zu spät ist, dann wird das Ganze wieder umgekehrt.
Weil urheberrechtlich geschützte Dateien bleiben, urheberrechtlich geschützte Dateien, egal wie man sie da rankommen will. Deswegen merken wir uns jamendo.com. Danke, Hans.
Wo wir noch so zehn Minuten haben, sollten wir auf jeden Fall noch auf eine Sache ganz dringend eingehen. Und zwar wird der Bundestag am 11. April die EU-Richtlinie zur Durchsetzung geistigen Eigentums beschließen. Die diskutieren sie seit ganzen fünf Jahren. Und dort ist unternahm ein sehr strittiger Punkt das sogenannte Auskunftsrecht. Und zwar im Moment läuft das ja alles so mit den Filesharingen. Also die ProMedia GmbH oder andere, die sitzen da, kriegen eine IP-Nummer, stellen eine Strafeanzeige bei der Staatsanwaltschaft. Und die, wenn sie jetzt nicht in Bruppertal oder Offenbach sitzen, kommen dem auch nach und liefern dann die Daten weiter, wenn die Strafeanzeige irgendwie fallen gelassen wird, zum zivilrechtlichen Verfahren. Das sogenannte Auskunftsrecht, damit möchten die Rechteinhaber sofort das Recht haben, quasi beim Provider anzurufen und zu sagen, wir haben hier die IP-Nummer XYZ und geben sie uns mal die Daten raus, ohne überhaupt den rechtsstaatlichen Umweg über die Staatsanwaltschaften zu machen. Und wenn die Union sich letztendlich durchsetzt, und das sieht halt so aus, dass die SPD da mitgehen wird, dann werden wir demnächst halt so ein Auskunftsrecht haben, spätestens über den Bundesrat. Und hier habt ihr noch die Möglichkeit, eure Bundestagsabgeordneten zu kontaktieren. Ich glaube, FDP, SPD und CDU sind für so ein Auskunftsrecht. Bei FDP bin ich mir jetzt nicht so ganz sicher, weil da auch Datenschutzbelange dabei sind, aber die sind sehr Urheberrecht verfolgungsfreundlich.
Kann man da vielleicht mal ein konkreteres Beispiel an für dieses Auskunftsrecht konstruieren? Was würde im Detail passieren?
Die ProMedia GmbH sitzt dann da und hat eine IP-Nummer. Sie sieht halt, du bist auf der anderen Seite mit Scooter Filesharing. Dann rufen sie sofort den Provider an, weil sie erkennen können, eine IP-Nummer gehört halt Telekom. Hier tauscht jemand einen Scooter, geben sie uns mal sofort die IP-Nummer. Die IP-Nummer sind die Kundendaten. Dann schicken sie dem Kunden sofort eine Abmahnung. Und quasi die Provider werden zu Hilfs-Scheriffs gemacht. Und ja, der ganze rechtsstaatliche Vorgang, das halt noch eine Staatsanwaltschaft sagen könnte, ne, das akzeptieren wir jetzt nicht. Das ist ein Bagatellfall oder sonst irgendwie, wird halt umgangen.
Vielleicht ein kleines Detail dazu. Also auch die Musikindustrie hat sich schon überlegt, wie man diese ganzen Abmahngeschichten und Benachrichtigungen von Internetprovidern und sowas auch effizienter gestalten kann, automatisieren. Das heißt, sie haben mittlerweile auch ein eigenes Dateiformat entwickelt, ein eigenes Kommunikationssystem, wie sich die Industrie, die Provider, sich über Rechtsverletzungen der Kunden informieren können und auch Auskunft abfragen können und sowas. Da haben die sich also schon Gedanken gemacht, wie man das technisch alles sehr automatisch machen kann. Und ja, wird sich dann zeigen, ob das Ganze dann auch vom Bundesverfassungsgericht Bestand hat. Ich persönlich habe da so ein bisschen meine Zweifel, wenn jetzt sogar schon die Vorratsdatenspeicherung und die Auskunftsrechte beschränkt haben, weil das ist ja nochmal eine ganz, ganz gröbere Form. Also das ist eigentlich so, es ist so völlig absurd, sowas zu fordern und diesen rechtsstaatlichen Weg zu umgehen, dass ich da meine Bedenken habe, dass das auch wirklich Bestand hat. Aber es wird natürlich jetzt erstmal verabschiedet werden und dann muss erstmal wieder jemand klagen. Und das ist eine ganz, eine ziemlich lästige Sache.
Und man muss halt noch zwei Sachen mehr beachten. Einerseits auf EU-Ebene ist schon der zweite Teil dieser Richtlinie zur Durchsetzung geistigen Eigentums beschlossen worden. Da geht es nicht um zivilrechtliche Maßnahmen. Wir halten so ein Auskunftsrecht. Da haben sie sofort irgendwie Kriminalisierung von Tauschbörsennutzern beschlossen. Das wird auch irgendwann auf Bundesebene kommen. Und irgendwann, wenn wir dann eine große Koalition haben, sieht es dann auch ganz schlecht damit aus. Das ist die eine Sache. Und was du meinst, diese automatisierten Verfahren in Frankreich. Und haben wir schon gesetzt, in England auch, glaube ich, jetzt. Und in Deutschland hat die Musikindustrie die Diskussion auch schon gestartet, dass man halt für Tauschbörsennutzung oder für illegales Filesharing erst mal eine Abmahnung bekommt und dann nach der zweiten oder dritten Abmahnung das Internet gekappt bekommt. Und das finde ich eigentlich eine unverschämte Forderung, dass man halt junge Menschen quasi von der Kommunikation ausschließt, weil sie Kultur getauscht haben.
Deswegen würde ich jetzt das letzte Wort nochmal in die große weite Welt geben, und zwar zu Christian aus Potsdam. Wir haben jetzt zwei Stunden lang über Pro- und Kontra Filesharing gesprochen. Wir haben viele technische und juristische Details angemerkt. Hans aus Leipzig hat eben gerade sehr schön gesagt, Filesharing, ja, alles ganz gut und schön. Es gibt andere Alternativen, die viel besser sind, wie zum Beispiel jamendo.com. Auch Christian möchte eine Alternative anbringen. Hallo Christian.
Ich habe vor einigen Jahren das auch mal ausprobiert und also einige Dateien runtergezogen. Und im Endeffekt fühlt das dann darin, dass ich mir einfach die CDs gekauft habe, weil das bringt es nicht. Und in der letzten Zeit war halt das Problem, dass man dann halt irgendwas sucht, was dann jeder hat, wartet zwei Wochen und hat dann keine Lust mehr. Hat mir auch erklärt, dass man dann auch schon bei halbem MP3s quasi schon was auf den Deckel kriegen kann. Ich habe es dann einfach sein gelassen. Aber halt mit der heftigeren Nutzung von Linux, was ich ja so nebenbei noch in der Uni mit benutze, braucht man die ja eigentlich wieder. Und da ist es ganz sinnvoll, dass man die P2P Netzwerke hat, weil man da richtig tolle Sachen so fürs Programm runterladen kann. Dann haben wir auch angefangen uns mit Open Source zu beschäftigen und ein paar Spiele zu suchen. Und die kann man ja alle darüber downloaden, ohne sich irgendwie vor irgendwem fürchten zu müssen. Und ja, dafür kann man es eigentlich ganz gut benutzen. Und da gibt es auch ganz nette Spielchen. Man muss nur ein bisschen suchen. Und da macht sich auch der Torrent ganz gut. Und ich nehme meistens die MyTorrent, weil der ist nicht so groß. Hat, glaube ich, nur zwei Megabytes. Passt auf jeden USB-Stick und kann man mitnehmen. Und läuft ganz gut. Und man muss sich da vor allem keine Sorgen machen, dass man das von der Firma erwischt wird.
Genau, also Tauschbörsen generell nicht nur für illegales Filesharing, sondern auch vorwiegend eigentlich vor allem BitTorrent. War wirklich ursprünglich auch gedacht dafür. Behaupte ich einfach mal so. Stell ich mal in den Raum und sag, BitTorrent ist eigentlich genau ein tolles Medium, ein tolles System, um wirklich große Mengen an Daten wie zum Beispiel CD-Images, also komplette DVDs mit Installationen, mit Software, vor allem mit freier Software natürlich und freier Musik und freien Filmen im Netz zu verbreiten. Tauschbörsen sind gut.
Und damit nehme ich jetzt, das war ein wunderbares Schlusswort, und damit nehme ich jetzt den Pfaden in die Hand und sage nochmal zu Christian, danke für den Anruf und dein Hinweis zum Schluss, wenn man sich ein bisschen damit beschäftigt, sich mit Open Source und Linux beschäftigt, findet man neue Möglichkeiten, wie man BitTorrent nutzen kann und der Rest der Welt der Satik nehme einfach jetzt meinen Rechner, werfe den Anwalt zu faulen, meine MP3s zu beschriften. Freunde, da braucht ihr euch nicht wundern, wenn ihr früher oder später irgendwann mal Post von einem Anwalt bekommt. Was dann passiert, darüber könnt ihr euch mit dem Anwalt eures Vertrauens unterhalten. Das auf jeden Fall war Chaosradio 133 mit Markus Becke da. Vielen Dank, dass du da warst. Mit Frank Rosengardt, herzlichen Dank. Genau, und wenn ihr Fragen habt, schickt eine Mail an chaosradio.ccc.de Und wenn ihr noch mehr Technik und Nerdkram machen wollt, Chaosradio Express, alles unter chaosradio.ccc.de Genau, jetzt geht's weiter mit dem Night Flight und André Langenfeld. Wir machen Tschüss für heute und sagen bis morgen oder so.